hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning more about article
six of the US Constitution Article six
is as will soon see kind of a
constitutional grab bag
it covers debts religious tests for
office and it establishes the
Constitution as the supreme law of the
land to learn more about what binds
these diverse ideas together I sought
out the help of two experts Kermit
Roosevelt is a professor of law
specializing in constitutional law and
conflict of laws at the University of
Pennsylvania Law School and Michael
Ramsey is professor of law and director
of international and comparative law
programs at the University of San Diego
School of Law so let's start out talking
about the debts portion of article six
professor Roosevelt why were the framers
so interested in dead what was the
historical context that led them to
explicitly address debt in article six
well debt is important generally because
nations often need to borrow money and
specifically with the Constitution and
the Articles of Confederation the US
government had been borrowing money to
pay for the Revolutionary War so there
was a question we're moving from a sort
of loose confederation almost like a
treaty between nations
under the Articles of Confederation to a
single unitary country with a stronger
national government under the
Constitution and there was a question is
it still the same country will the new
United States pay the debts of the old
United States now there's a general
principle of international law that a
successor government undertakes the
obligations of the predecessor so you
wouldn't necessarily think this would be
a problem but I think they were
particularly concerned because the idea
of a republic was a somewhat new one at
least in the 18th century somewhat
unusual one and the the the change of a
Republican government might cause some
worries in Europe where where this money
was owed so I think they just wanted to
reassure all of the creditors that even
if they were changing their method of
government that that wasn't going to
affect any of the debts what might have
happened had they decided not to pay
those debts if they decided not
pay the debts then other countries would
probably have been much less willing to
lend money to the new United States
because they might have thought well you
know another change in government could
occur there was substantial question
throughout the world whether the United
States would be able to survive in the
face of all the challenges that they had
after gaining their independence so in
order to make it seem that they that the
United States was a country that could
be trusted the country that could be
expected to stick around and not
collapse in the chaos or revert to
colonial status one of the most
important things for them was to show
that the the debts would be honored
because a failure to honor debts would
suggest that the country did not in fact
have true sovereignty and was not
prepared to be a actor on the
international stage that could be
trusted another interesting thing to
contrast this to is the treatment of
debts after the Civil War where of
course the United States the federal
government paid its own debts but
there's a provision in the 14th
amendment explicitly repudiating the
Confederate debt so if you loaned money
to the Confederate States of America
you're never getting that back because
we didn't treat that as a valid
government that would be continued going
forward another thing that it
illustrates is that the Constitution in
some respects was was a visionary
document that was concerned with a
long-term future of the United States
but in other respects it responded to
very immediate practical problems that
the framers faced in their day they were
thinking about not not just the future
of the country for the ages and they
were thinking about that but but they
weren't thinking just about that they
were they were also thinking about
reassuring France with respect to the
debts that existed right at that moment
so there's a lot going on in article 6
and specifically it talks about the
Constitution as the supreme law of the
land so what's important about that
statement what's important about that is
that it means the Constitution is our
highest law it prevails over any other
kind of law in a conflict so one thing
that that means is the Constitution is
supreme over state law and then the
Constitution actually goes on to talk
about that a little bit more but it also
means the Constitution is supreme over
federal law so everyone is bound by the
Constitution
the states can't bill against it
Congress can't go past it the president
can't violate constitutional
restrictions the Constitution is really
the last word it's the pinnacle or the
keystone of the arch of American
democracy
and that's why we can say that things
are unconstitutional that laws are
unconstitutional and therefore invalid
and most importantly it's why the
Supreme Court can say that laws are
unconstitutional and not in and invalid
it creates a superior law that that
limits the laws that can be passed by
the other parts of the government it
creates a hierarchy of laws and in doing
so it assures that we have a single set
of rules that applies to all the states
and to the federal government and it
can't be changed except by an amendment
which is relatively difficult to do
there's a procedure in the Constitution
for how you can amend the Constitution
but until amended the Constitution as as
written is our superior law and that
that was different from the way that the
framers the law rules the framers were
used to under the English system where
they didn't have a written constitution
and an unwritten Constitution but that
that Constitution was subject to change
by Parliament so has this supremacy of a
constitution been tested over time there
haven't been a lot of claims that the
Constitution is not supreme so generally
speaking everyone gives at least lip
service to this idea what's been tested
is more the question of who gets to
decide what the Constitution means and
when something conflicts with it so if
you want the Constitution and federal
law to be supreme probably you would
want to have someone in the federal
government deciding when there's a
conflict say with state law and the
forms that resistance has taken over the
years or more states saying not you know
we can go against the Constitution we're
above the Constitution but States saying
we don't think what we're doing violates
the Constitution right and you the
Supreme Court you think it does but
you're wrong in the 19th century just
before the Civil War
the Supreme Court decided in the Dred
Scott case that african-americans could
not be citizens of the United States
even if they were freed slaves and
President Lincoln believes that that was
wrong he said that there was nothing in
the Constitution that denied that the
ability of them to be citizens and and
he said that the Supreme Court had
misunder interpreted the Constitution
and he would not accept the Supreme
Court's ruling in that regard later in
the twentieth century
the Supreme Court held that the
Constitution barred segregation
particularly in in schools in the Brown
versus Board of Education case but many
southern governors and other
institutions throughout the South
thought that the Supreme Court had
gotten that one wrong and they refused
to abide by what the Supreme Court had
said the Constitution means what they
said was not the Constitution doesn't
bind us but we know what the
Constitution means better than you
Supreme Court you're wrong you're making
this up it's political it's not judging
another thing that article six talks
about is religious tests why were the
framers so interested in preventing
religious tests in government what sort
of historical evils were they trying to
prevent so this is connected to the
basic idea of the separation of church
and state and you separate church and
state really to protect both of those
things so you want to protect religion
from being corrupted by political
considerations but you also want to
protect your political system from being
a battleground between rival religions
so where this comes from is that in
England they had had a series of what
they called test acts and what the test
acts did was it required that for people
to be eligible for government offices
that that people had to be members of
the Church of England and that other
other religious groups they were barred
by the test acts from holding government
office so actually many of those
minority religions many adherents of
those ended up coming to the American
colonies to gain some measure of
religious freedom
the pilgrims were an example of that
there were there was a Catholic colony
and in Maryland
and just generally speaking many of the
people many of the colonists who came
over were people who were not part of
the main established church in England
and so you can see why they would not
want to have something like the test
acts and they wanted to make clear that
in the new national government that that
any religion or no religion would would
be allowed for for government office
holders do you think it's true that we
don't have religious tests or oaths in
the United States how about the practice
of swearing on a Bible during the
presidential inauguration
well the practice of swearing on a Bible
is very interesting as is the fact that
when the president recites the oath of
office every president going back to
George Washington has added on to the
end of it so help me God there's
actually an oath in the Constitution the
president has to swear to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution but
the Constitution doesn't say so help me
God
the president's just add that on on
their own and actually that sort of
illustrates the way in which the
Constitution treats religion which is it
can't be part of government in an
official sense but we know that members
of government are also people and they
have religious beliefs that are
important to them and we don't demand
that they exclude religion from their
lives we just demand that it be
separated from government authority so
you can swear on a Bible if you want to
you don't have to you can swear on some
other religious book we had a member of
Congress take an oath of office on a
Koran so individual government officials
are allowed to include religion insofar
as it's about them personally you know
what you think is appropriate to mark
this occasion
what celebified's this oath for you you
can do that but we can't require it and
they can't make the exercise of their
power religious in nature so you can't
you know as a government official
exercise your power on religious grounds
it's something that strikes me about
article six is that it addresses so many
different things do you have a sense of
why debts and constitutional supremacy
and religious tests are all in one
article article six as you said is a
little bit of a grab bag it's not
entirely clear how these different
pieces of article six relate to each
other and I think they were just things
that the framers wanted in the
Constitution and didn't know for sure
where else to put them I'm not exactly
sure why the debts are there if I had to
say something about article six it would
be it's sort of the glue that holds the
constitutional architecture together so
maybe the debts are in there to explain
the continuity between the US government
under the Articles of Confederation and
the US government under the Constitution
then the Supremacy Clause explains how
all of the different parts of the
federal system are supposed to fit
together and what the Supremacy Clause
is saying is the Constitution is above
all of them the Constitution connects
them all everyone has to abide by the
Constitution and it tells you you know
the Constitution is the highest log then
you've got federal law and then below
that is state law so that if there's a
conflict between federal law and state
law the federal law is going to win and
then the last part of article six is
sort of doing the same thing because you
know what holds the country together
what binds people into a single people
in a lot of countries at the time of the
founding it was religion right religion
was the glue that held the society
together and if you weren't a member of
that religion you were an outsider he
were a second-class citizen you would be
shunned and and not given equal rights
in some ways the last Clause of Article
six says something sort of similar about
America except it explicitly says it's
not religion that binds us together
right no religious test can be required
but you do have to take an oath what do
you have to pledge to support you have
to pledge to support the Constitution so
there again it's telling you the
Constitution is what we all have in
common that's what makes us Americans
that really is the glue that binds our
society together so we've learned that
article
sex is as professor Roosevelt put it the
glue that binds the country together in
assuming the debts from the era of the
Articles of Confederation article six
establish the continuity of US
government it also placed the
Constitution not religion as the supreme
law of the United States to learn more
about article six visit the National
Constitution Center's interactive
Constitution and Khan Academy's
resources on US government and politics